who knew what and when waron answered
questions about the raid the white house
has said they didn't know a thing before
it happened but if true
why hasn't biden come out to demand more
transparency my next guest is trying to
get to the bottom of this joining me now
is florida senator rick scott chair of
the national republican senatorial
committee all right senator good to see
you
um
where's joe biden been on all this uh
how has he not said anything you know i
know the man wants to be on vacation and
no he has a hard time taking questions
from the folks but why hasn't he spoken
out about such a big move by the fbi and
the doj
well first off is biden always on
vacation is it every week but or just
seems that way i mean he's always out
i mean think about this where is biden
why wouldn't he demand
you know he's going to be you know he's
going to be a former president someday
why wouldn't he sit there and demand
transparency this is unprecedented a
former president potential opponent to a
sitting president with an administration
by administration who's already targeted
opponents like parents at school board
meetings so we've got to get to the
bottom of this one we need to have a
hearing i'm on the homeland security
committee uh we need to have a hearing
we need to have ray and garland come in
and tell us exactly uh what they know
why they did it what what was the
evidence they gave to the judge what
insurance documents they have
we actually we need all that today we
need them to come out and be be
transparent republicans we're going to
take control in november when we do
all the information is going to come out
we'll find out exactly what happened but
this is unprecedented i don't know where
biden is i guess he's on vacation
getting ice cream again but he ought to
demand transparency like all of us you
know
joe biden ran as the great unifier you
look at what this is doing
amongst the other things he's done is
ripping the country apart but do you
think that the senate can actually get
the doj and the fbi to comply with your
quest i know you wrote a letter to
merrick garland recently will they
comply with the request of the senate
well i'll tell you what if christopher
wray intern general garland if they want
to have a reputation when they finish
these jobs they need you know and both
of them have said
all right because i've talked to both of
them they believe in congress's right of
oversight if they believe in congress's
right of oversight they can give they
should be able to give us all the
information if they want to give it to
me in a classified setting they can do
that but the american public needs to
have a much better understanding of why
they did this what information did they
have
why the judge made the decision there's
a lot of unanswered questions here and
they're hurting themselves and they're
hurting this great country you know
senator money talks right so i i did
oversight on the financial services
committee and they totally stonewalled
me they sent me you know press clippings
and news releases
um they might say they're going to
cooperate and they might say they want
transparency but the only thing that's
going to drive them to comply with your
requests is when you withhold their
money you say you know what we're going
to cut your budgets you're not getting
cash from the congress because we hold
the power of the purse you're not going
to get it unless you provide those
documents do you think the senate and
the house will go that far
i expect them to i mean we look we we've
got to take our country back we've got
to fight for this country we've got to
stop having these career politicians
making all these decisions we got to
stop this partisanship that's going on
up there so we have got to do this by
the way we have got to win in november
if you want to help i tell everybody
text win to 55404 we've got to get the
majority back we will do everything we
can to hold these individuals
accountable senator and then after you
get the documents then get rid of the
the federal unions clear all these deep
staters out that's the next thing but
listen senator i appreciate you joining
me tonight thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else